turkey has been struck by a powerful
earthquake off its aegean coast
causing buildings to collapse in the
coastal city of izmir
the quake's epicenter was north of the
greek island of samos
with the u.s geological survey putting
it at a magnitude of
7.0 tremors were felt as far away as
athens and istanbul in izmir social
media footage
showed a collapsed building there are no
immediate reports of
casualties
so for more we are now joined by dw
correspondent dorian jones in istanbul
dorian
what did it feel like where you are
well in fact i did feel the tremor from
this very powerful earthquake even
though it occurred several hundred
kilometers away from
istanbul but it was significant enough
that you could actually feel it here in
istanbul so there is already a great
deal of concern
for where the epicenter of the
earthquake is is near turkey's third
largest city
and it is also a reminder of people in
istanbul of the ongoing threat of
earthquakes
so what are you uh hearing uh from local
media reports and
uh eventually about possible casualties
well what we understand is the initial
report says that this earthquake was
anywhere between 6.6 and 7.1 on the
richter scale now that is a very
powerful earthquake
for turkey uh there we got reports that
uh from the city of izmir which like i
said is turkey's third largest city
they caused widespread panic throughout
the city people ran out onto the streets
we've seen already images of buildings
shaking
violently there isn't any reports at the
moment of casualties but this is a very
powerful earthquake
uh the it believes that the epicenter of
the earthquake was something in the
region of 15 kilometers into the aegean
sea
near the greek island of samos um it has
uh caused a great deal of concern that
this region is very prone to a powerful
earthquake as is the rest of turkey
and this is will be now a concern that
there will be possible casualties there
aren't any reports of major structures
failing
but turkey does have a record of
powerful earthquakes hitting the country
and causing widespread damage to
buildings
well as you say turkey has a record of
earthquakes
so do people generally know how to react
well as you turkey the whole of turkey
in fact is prone to violent earthquakes
in fact here in istanbul uh
in the late 1990s uh just outside
istanbul over 20
000 people were killed in a devastating
quake in
the nearby city of izmit and that was
called a profound shock throughout the
country
and then these powerful earthquakes
causing thousands of casualties
isn't unusual for turkey and in fact
istanbul is
according to experts long overdue for
another very powerful earthquake and now
given the fact of these dangers there
are now preparations uh in uh
prepared for major quakes people are now
given information about what to do
uh in the in the event of an earthquake
in
fact classes schools it is part of the
education to prepare for a quake so
there is this education process going on
turkey is developing an infrastructure
to deal with these quakes that
infrastructure is now in action in izmir
and preparations like for cities like
istanbul
is also a large amount of preparation by
the authorities national and local
because
there is the understanding that living
in turkey carries the threat of major
earthquakes
and with that the danger of risk of life
there's also a major efforts are taking
place to
build more safe buildings the deadly
earthquake that happened in 1990s in
turkey
many of the thousands of casualties was
blamed on the fact that the buildings
were not adequately
uh built to withstand major quakes
narrow
since that earthquake there is a lot
more regulation on the construction of
buildings but having said that
the risk of death does live with people
living in turkey with earthquakes
dorian jones they're reporting on
today's 7.0 earthquake
hitting turkey and greece thank you
dorian